this video is sponsored by upper story
more about them later on the 25th of
April 2018 the Cernic's Sentinel 3B
satellite was launched from the placet
cosmodrome after clearing the atmosphere
over the course of several weeks it
fired its thrusters to position itself
in a sun synchronous orbit 500 m above
the surface once in this position it
orbited the Earth every 100 minutes
sweeping the entire surface area every
27 days the satellite and its
instruments formed just part of the
European space agency's monitoring of
Earth's clim clim adding to data sets of
temperature Wildfire activity and many
more variables that have been collected
for decades but before that new data
could be added to existing climate data
sets it had to go through a rigorous
verification process and for good reason
so many decisions being made today are
based on observations of the earth's
climate which scientists find alarming
the impacts of these decisions are vast
and so we have to be absolutely sure we
are basing them on the best data
possible to that end in 1992 the global
climate observing system was established
in cooperation with organizations like
the World Meteorological organization
and the United Nations environment
program they decided on 55 key variables
to characterize the earth's climate
which merited specific standardized
monitoring and they call them essential
climate variables they Define a list of
55 variable also called essential
climate uh variables this is a group of
variables that represent climate at best
and we have 55 of them distributed in
the different compartment of the earth
system in the atmosphere in the ocean
and over the land this is Dr clemon Abel
a scientist at the European space
agency's climate office and the climate
office's job is to create long-term
global data sets of those ecvs more than
half of them can benefit from satellite
Earth observation and some of them can
entirely rely on Earth observation so
developing this core group of variable
is at the core of isas climate change
initiative however the tricky part is
that the data for a specific variable
like say ground temperature can come
from multiple sources multiple
satellites that more often than not
overlap in time but why is that a
problem imagine that you want to record
a piece of live music so you set up a
microphone and hit record but it quickly
becomes clear that your microphone is
about to run out of battery so you
scramble around and get your backup
microphone and hit record there's some
overlap between these second microphone
being turned on and the first one dying
however it turns out that your second
microphone is also nearly out of charge
and the piece isn't finished yet so you
go to your Backup backup microphone and
set that recording too again there's
some overlap between the second and
third microphones finally the piece
finishes and you're left with three
different recordings using three
different microphones of the same piece
together they form a complete recording
but they all sound slightly different
how do you combine them in a a seamless
recording of the whole piece now I think
that what we have to keep in mind is
that there is no satellite mission that
last uh forever so what we want to
develop is long time series and only
long time series can be useful for uh to
study uh climate so it's very important
to put together information from various
uh instrument to try to obtain uh
harmonized time series of essential
climate variable surface moisture is one
of them and in order to develop a global
time series of some more spanning from
1978 to the current time we needed to
put together information from 17 uh
sensors that are flying up there I mean
different sensors will observe the same
variables but in different uh condition
with different uh specific one can be
biased compared to the other so we need
to uh develop techniques to be able to
remove this bias so we can uh appreciate
the variables in time uh oh b word b we
got the b word bias in everyday language
we say that something or someone is
biased if they have an inclination
towards or a prejudice against a
particular group of people or a
particular conclusion for example we
might say that a hiring firm has a
similarity bias if they only hire people
who look like they do or if a newspaper
only publishes articles about
peer-reviewed Research into how the
climate is rapidly changing and no
articles about how scientists are woke
we might say they have a bias towards
reality people hear removing bias in a
climate context and assume that means
that scientists are cherry-picking and
removing data such that it matches a
conclusion that they have come to in
advance and that's simply not true and
it comes down to language in a
statistical context bias means something
very different it simply means a
statistical deviation of an observation
from reality for example imagine you
have a measuring jug with markings on
the side because of a printing error
however the markings are slightly too
high when you fill it with water to the
100ml line you've actually filled it
with 110 mL of water you could verify
this by weighing the volume of water
you've poured Into The Jug in other
words using a verification measurement
the measuring jug is still useful it's
just biased by 10 mlit any measurement
you make with it just needs to have that
bias removed when scientists talk about
removing biases this this is what
they're talking about verifying the
accuracy of a new measurement with
another already calibrated form of
measurement and then subtracting any
bias that's been identified from new
measurements made by that new method
there's nothing nefarious about it and
notes that the verification process
isn't always perfect in fact I did a
video a few years ago on how satellites
were underestimating the warming Trend
in Africa because of verification issues
but I digress before the data from
Sentinel 3 B can be added to the
existing data set of ground surface
temperatures it has to be validated
using Inu measurements it has to have
its bias removed and that's not
something done by hand scientists like
clor are not going in and changing
individual numbers to match some
predetermined conclusion like I don't
know a warming Trend and that's because
it would take way too long we want to
have that as a automated as uh as
possible you you always need a last
human quality check at least at least
for now but yes also to having automated
activity such as this one permit to
limit the possibility to have an error
so to go back to our analogy of
recording a piece of live music using
multiple microphones each microphone has
a bias in this specific case we could
just say that our first microphone is
the correct level and so we adjust the
levels of each subsequent microphone to
match the first something we can easily
do because of the overlaps between the
microphones
but what if instead of using one
microphone at a time you had a whole
array of them multiple microphones at
once dropping in and out all with
different biases at a given time what is
the correct measurement and what if
these slightly different microphones
measure bass and treble frequencies
slightly differently or pick up on these
slightly different parts of the room
it's a really hard problem made Harder
by the fact that there is a true answer
to look for and getting this right has
huge impacts on global decision- making
this is what it's actually like trying
to create a long-term climate data set
instead of microphones you have
satellites and instead of a musical
group you have 55 different but related
climate variables but we also have
period of time more uh recently where we
have to combine all this information to
obtain a single value of Soul moisture
at each location of Earth and to be
clear that's not easy that's not easy no
that's not easy and it requires a lot of
development and algorithm and also
choice on how to use these data rather
than the other it's not as simple as
making a big average of all the data you
have at one point in uh in time the
specifics of how you do that are to be
completely honest not very interesting
they're just a bunch of predetermined
algorithms and statistics designed to
match satellite observations with those
that are taken on the ground it's a
verification process that involves
multiple biases for each satellite
unfortunately though where some people
see dense boring statistics like that
they see a smoke screen for nefarious
activity just this summer online there
was quite a bit of confusion mostly
spread by unqualified influencers about
the difference between ground
temperature which is measured by
Sentinel 3B and air temperature or 2 m
temperature which is not Sentinel 3 has
a radiometer that measure L surface
temperature that is not air temperature
at the meterological sense but rather
the amount of energy that is radiating
from the earth how it will F uh to the
touch in a Summer clear sky condition
land surface temperature depending on
the cover on the color of the cover and
the the cloud fraction of the wind then
surface temperature can be way higher
than 2 m uh temperature the difference
between those two measurements led to
claims that Isa was trying to scare
Monga about climate change claims that
spread online like wildfire like the
wildfire that was actually spreading
across Europe due to 2023 being the
warmest summer on record watching this
controversy from the outside was
immensely frustrating because to me as
an observer it was pretty clear that at
the very least some of the confusion was
deliberately manufactured by climate
Skeptics either mislabeling figures or
being ambiguous about which variable was
being used in a particular figure
although you know some of it probably
was just genuine confusion these are two
quite similar but very distinct
variables and humans are fallible it
could be it could be a bit of boss I
would uh I would say we always have to
be very careful when we have a new type
of information uh and to bet to
understand the the context and where
does it come from and I agree that if
some one is providing fake news or Del
deliberately willing to take an
information out of its uh context it's
quite uh easy to create uh some wrong
information and to attract a lot of of
attention but it do never been the
intention of Isa to bring confusion that
sentence right there is why I wanted to
make this video because issa's climate
office and other Earth observation
organizations are not interested in
coming to some pred determined
conclusion they're certainly not
interested in spreading confusion their
sole purpose is to observe the Earth
system in as much accuracy as possible
and report what they find that's it they
don't get any more money for finding any
particular findings they have no
incentive to choose algorithms or
manipulate the data to be anything other
than the most accurate representation of
the earth system possible removing the
biases from each sensor from each
satellite and combining them to give the
scientific Community the highest quality
information possible if there were any
biases on display this summer they
weren't from satellites they were from
commentators online determined to deny
the science that the Earth is warming it
is because we have the global climate
observing system and the long-term data
sets from Issa and elsewhere that we
know the climate is warming far faster
than anything in the historical record
that wasn't a conclusion that scientists
came to and then found the data to
support it's what the data showed us
from space but also on the ground over
and over and over again and I can ensure
you that no climate scientist is happy
about all what we see uh currently in
the in the news so we will prefer a
different outcome for sure hopefully one
day The Sentinel program and its
successors will document a planet that
instead of warming more and more
stabilizes its temperature and
eventually cools adding to a really
impressive temperature data set that
hopefully you now understand a little
bit better as some of you know recently
my wife and I welcomed our first child
into the world and obviously one of the
big perks of having a kid is you get to
spend more time playing with toys some
of the best toys are the ones you used
to get at the science museum gift shop
if you're anything like me you used to
go to a science museum and you'd see
something really cool that was like a
demonstration of a concept in physics or
chemistry or engineering that you just
saw in the museum but as a toy and you
almost never got to take it home hold
those toys in your mind because this
video is sponsored by upper story and
their spintronics kit which updates
those toys to the modern day and makes
me really excited for two reasons
firstly I always struggled with circuits
when I was a student it took me ages to
get the physical difference between
current and voltage and spintronics
makes those kinds of distinctions really
obvious by using physical components to
create a mechanical analog of an elect
El ronic circuit instead of wires it
uses chains that's your battery so if I
pull it there's no resistance so this is
just going to short yep these are your
resistors that's 500 ohms 1,000 ohms and
they're going to resist motion that's
going to resist more than that will
that's the
Amer oh that must be the capacitor
that's your switch oh yeah so that
doesn't move now it does right hang on
let's make a simple circuit let's make a
simple circuit this is the first time
I've seen Electronics Tau in such a
practical physical way and it really
works it takes Concepts that are very
abstract and it makes them tangible and
this is something that upper stories
have history with their previous product
was uring tumble which was an
award-winning marble powered computer
that they used to teach computer sence
I've got another plate and it Clips in
pops in and then twist and
then
magnets put the loop around the
top I love so because you've got
resistance to the voltage that you're
applying you don't get infinite current
you don't short it
out it actually has a stable current we
do that and then we pop the Amer on the
top then this
should oh this is so good this is so
clever the box contains a puzzle book
with steampunk narrative elements and
setups for puzzles as well as the
components used used and you can do
these puzzles Solo or collaboratively
it's a really unique way to teach this
stuff and when upper story reached out I
couldn't say yes fast enough because
it's just so Innovative it's exactly the
kind of toy that I would have loved to
have played with when I was a kid and
frankly as an adult now I'm gassed to go
through these puzzles they're not just
for kids but looking to the Future the
other reason I was so excited for this
sponsorship is this is exactly the kind
of thing I cannot wait to play
collaboratively with my daughter
appropriate for ages to adult if you
would like to learn or teach Electronics
in a mechanical way head to Upper
story.com spintronics and if you use the
code Simon Clark all caps you'll get 10%
off that's upper story.com spintronics
with thanks to Upper story for
sponsoring this video and for giving
pixel baby a really cool toy thank you
so much for watching and of course thank
you to Clore at the European Space
Agency along with Paul and Suzanne you
guys were wonderfully generous with your
time thank you for allowing me to make
this video the names you're seeing on
the screen right now are some of my
executive producer patrons who saw some
behind the scenes of my filming trip at
the European Space Agency in the monthly
Vlog that I make exclusively for my
patrons if you'd like to support the
channel and help me make more and better
content and get exclusive stuff in
return and there's a link to my patreon
in the description if you enjoyed the
video please do pop it a like and give
it a share on your socials in fact why
not give it a share with that person in
your life who you think could do with
hearing the content of this video if
you'd like to watch something next
here's some recommended viewing that
just leaves me to say thank you again
for watching I'll see you in the next
one